Was ist denn der Rohstoff für die Industrie?
Kluge, gute Köpfe,
gute Unternehmer, also Bildung und Forschung,
unstrittig und auch günstig
verfügbare Energie,
die wir brauchen. Vor allem für die Chemie Industrie.
Für die grundstoffindustrie, sei es Zement,
sei es Papier,
sei es glasindustrie und da kommts doch drauf an,
in Zukunft einen günstigen,
sauberen Strompreis zu haben,
dass auch sauber is, um CO 2 Werte einhalten zu können.
Und da wär doch der grüne Industrie Strom
genau die richtige Antwort.
Und es wär aber sinnvoll,
auch im eigenen Land Windkraftanlagen zügig zuzubauen.
Und richtig,
es gibt jetzt die 1. größeren Parks in südbayern.
Chemiedreieck haben wir unterstützt.
Is richtig, is n entscheidender Schritt.
Aber entscheidend is auch,
dass wir in den nächsten Jahren schnell vorankommen.
Und dafür brauchen wir 2 Prozent der Landesfläche,
um schneller genehmigten zu können.
Genehmigungszeit wird auf Bundesebene
von 8 auf 4 Jahren halbiert
ist n 1. Schritt.
Wir können noch besser werden eines Tages.
Der 1. Schritt
greift aber nur in vorranggebieten
und dann wollen sie die vorranggebiete in Bayern
erst im Jahre bis zum Jahre 2.022 ausweisen.
Da verlieren wir doch 9 Jahre.
Machen wir das doch,
bis Ende 2.024 kriegen wir die Windkraft in Bayern
voran mit der Solarkraft mit Biomasse als
erneuerbare sicherheitsenergie,
dann wird doch n Schuh draus.
Pack mal das doch endlich mal an,
Bayern wirklich zum Vorreiter der Energiewende
zu machen.